welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me grace Helbig we have a very
exciting guest today if you like kpop
you're gonna love Eric because I've
learned that kpop rules via the internet
it's very it's very in very trendy Eric
is a singer a songwriter a TV host and
he interviewed Jamie Foxx once and she
got Jamie Foxx to sing his actual
original song you'll hear all about it
he also has a podcast it turns out he
doesn't like but maybe he's just making
us get ready for this episode of not too
deep with Eric Nam turn your great idea
into a reality with Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project whether you're
showcasing your work or selling products
of any kind with beautiful templates and
the ability to customize just about
anything you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself but if you do
get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help head to Squarespace comm / grace
for a free trial and when you are ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain we're going we're
going hey guy thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me okay you
just said am I allowed to say this that
you're going to Vegas tomorrow sure why
not
okay and you're going to Vegas because
my one of my brother's is getting
married okay and but I've never been to
Vegas mm-hmm so Bryan who's my youngest
brother and I were co-best men okay and
we've been charged with planning this
bachelor party Wow
but I should I should stay I've a never
been to a bachelor party okay I've never
been to a wedding as a full-grown adult
Wow
we want a first for you guys you're
getting thrown to the wolves I'm I feel
very attacked in many ways so your your
brother basically owes both of you for
this pretty much yeah do you have
anything planned for the bachelor party
I mean we have good restaurants we have
you know some apparently like day
parties and day drinking as things do so
we have a couple of those things cool
and
and tattoos tattoos bad decisions
yeah I'm sure they're all come in you
know play some way or the other
lots of good stuff who's playing in
Vegas right now you guys can go see it
got who JLo I mean that seems right up
your alley
jail you're amazing if you want to
collab for it I don't know if I would go
to your show on my own volition
there you go you know unless you get
this free ticket right the tickets are
expensive they're a couple hundred bucks
I'm sure they are thing I wouldn't sell
Backstreet Boys in Vegas yeah that's
what I said after they answered the DM
that I said um unbelievable I lost my
[ __ ] mind it was so good right but I
have a secret confession yes so I watch
Backstreet Boys in high school no it was
like freshman year college huh like I
grew up on that entire hop genre like a
street boys and saving the same freaking
Hansen whatever
remember Disney Channel I'm sure we were
there at like the peak oh yeah they had
this summer concert series where it was
we didn't have Disney Channel in my
house because we were super not wealthy
enough no so I got to imagine what was
on Disney Channel but Hansen I remember
was like one of the first CDs that I
bought right it was these were legendary
moments in my childhood and I remember
it was like freshman year at college
after yeah I gone home for the first
time we're like the Backstreet Boys our
play we should and then one of my
friends like oh my parents have like the
membership so we can go for free I was
like I will pay you for free tickets
yeah so I think Brian the youngest
brother he was probably like eight at
the time and I took him to his first
concert you went to see the Backstreet
Boys when you're eight years old do you
even remember that though so privileged
did so I mean to tie this into a little
bit about what you do
today mm-hmm well first of all because
in doing all this research about you you
are this hybrid career monster the
person in the world so I like to ask
people like that that are on the podcast
what's your deal what's my deal yeah
like how do you explain yourself to
people that don't know you well first of
all everybody buckled down real quick
take a deep deep breath take a moment um
what am I I am a I guess a singer
songwriter TV host okay entrepreneur
investor person sounds great I mean I
just like through a bunch of cool
sounding words into a sentence they all
sound legit you know I'm I fake most of
it mm-hmm to be quite honest welcome to
the club
but no it's it's I think I was
explaining someone earlier today that I
feel like the modern-day celebrity or
singer-songwriter whatever you have to
be everywhere doing everything yeah you
know and so for whatever reason we've
evolved into these multi-headed monsters
that have to do everything yeah I mean
it it's so true that like lots of pots
on the stove and to make a bigger meal
right just one right and because the way
that we kind of like social media markt
everything that we do like you have to
be kind of like mm-hmm expert
quote-unquote in different fields
instead of just focusing on one thing
and hoping someone else will do
everything else but that's really
admirable and also exhausting it's that
I was gonna say that it's exhausting
yeah I'm sure but you get to work with
your brothers yeah which is so cool it
is cool and you guys live together
Brian's like based here in LA now okay
um Eddie who's our other feathers based
in LA but they come out to Korea very
often regularly and then I come out to
LA New York a few times a year just to
get things done cool so you guys grew up
in Atlanta right and then okay take us
from Atlanta to ending up in Korea oh
yeah
so yeah born and raised in Atlanta
and then I went to Boston College okay
and I studied international relations
political science kind of stuff and
pretty much I felt like I went through
college checking off every single
checklist that every parent or case
agents would want you to do so I had you
know the grades I had all the
internships I knocked everything off and
by the end of my senior year by the time
I was graduating I had a job offer at
Deloitte Consulting so I was supposed to
be a strategy and operations consultant
that sounds with a single tear down
their cheek
we're how empowering you through this
but so they they gave me the the job
offer but in my claws I was like I'll
join if I take a year off if he do that
savvy so they said sure do whatever you
want just let us know and so you know
for me it was like I could probably be
you know ten years into my career and
I'll probably have like that
two and a half kids white picket fence
kind of thing going on very traditional
which is great but that also terrified
me like yeah I don't know why but that
was suffocating to me I had the same
feelings I feel I felt like it would
make me feel stuck right yeah and so I
was like let's just try whatever the
hell I wanted to try and so for me I
always grew up really loving Social Work
and philanthropy and then music and
entertainment and both were frowned upon
by my parents not because they're bad
but they're like you're not gonna make a
living anyway right but I was like I
have the job I could do whatever I want
I'm gonna take a year off so natural
decision is to go to India from Boston
to India yeah I mean it's a choice it's
a decision yeah and I was there for like
a social enterprise fellowship okay and
makes more sense than just blindly going
to India
Eat Pray Love so I went and
unfortunately I didn't have like the
best experience there I think the
program that I went with was in such an
early stage that it wasn't really
developed to really help us do what we
were there to do okay
and so I I was like really for the first
I was like depressed because I was like
I'm here in India mm-hmm I'm miserable
Oh like I don't want to do anything I
got to get out of here yeah and I had
been doing YouTube videos since like
high school mm-hmm and there it was just
like a hobby and I was like legit I was
like dear Lord I'm praying to you get me
out of here and I in like a few days I
got an email on my YouTube account
did you like you know you get so many
spammy emails and you don't really ever
check them and then there's that one
moment where something catches your eye
that happened to me wow it was we will
pay for your flight
send us your passport good bye bye I was
like what am I gonna lose just send him
with my passport they didn't want my
social security number but I just
thought I'd be an overachiever so I said
it to him that's how desperate I was
uh-huh and they sent me a flight and
then I got to Korea I was on like an
American Idol kind of thing got to top
five uh-huh quit my job signed a label
deal Wow
and how old are you at the time I was 22
22 okay probably okay so that was two
thousand eleven and twelve okay so I've
been in Korea for about almost eight
years oh wow
and then you went um after you signed
with a label then you were hosting you
started getting into like TV hosting and
TV right yeah so in Korea then it's like
how do you get your stuff out there how
do you be able to recognize you and I
had stuff off of the TV show like the
American Idol kind of thing yeah nothing
that was like my own yeah and so then
they started putting me out onto all
these talk shows and
shows and mind you my Korean was
horrendous oh you weren't even fluent
when you were going to do that really I
had no I would sit there for hours like
taping her like 8 to 12 hours long yeah
I have no idea what's going like I am
this idiot like Korean American kids
sitting there and I'm just like if
someone's laughing you just laugh yeah
you just laugh happier than anyone else
and if someone's saying oh you say all
sad anyone else and so I did that for a
while and then like the equivalent of
enews was like do you want to be a
correspondent for all these
international people coming to Korea
okay I'm sure I'll try it you know more
press and that's what really kind of
took off that with an English program I
was hosting doing kpop stuff for a
global community well but the interview
so like my first interview I think was
Robert Downey jr. real light bright star
super super - very easy welcoming into
the world of interview right we really
ease into it like press junket stuff so
they will fly over to Korea for their
like Iron Man press yeah and then David
give me like 30 minutes or 15 minutes or
however I used to do this for attack of
the show out here and I'd only get four
minutes yeah they did that when I flew
out to LA for spider-man with Andrew
Garfield and Emma Stone they're like
okay five minutes but the plane next to
a toilet for 12 hours and I have five
minutes and but the the you know it was
great is so I walked in Emma Stone was
like oh you're from Korea I love Korea I
love kpop oh okay we're gonna get this
any of you started and they're like
three minutes I was like what no like
she said hi I was like you know so
literally that interview was like nice
to meet you she was like I love kpop by
oh my god and so the next one was Jamie
Foxx mm-hmm and I walked in and the
producer was freaking I was like we flew
here from Korea and we have three
minutes of her saying
hey pops why don't we catch him
pressures on Ricky so I step into the
room of Jamie Foxx and he was like the
best gave such a cool interview and then
he was like I was like Oh calm down
style was big at the time yeah I start
talking about kpop and I was like I'm
the singer myself he's like assume your
song and he learned my song in Korean on
the spot Wow and then he was like his to
his assistant he's like I want you to
film this put it up on our all our
socials he was like I'm here with Eric
Nam he's like a great singer like
interviewer and you guys check out his
music and the interview went like 15
minutes and so I was like damn
incredible but yeah that's how like this
stuff in Korea really started to take
off things so I have my music going my
MC stuff and then like the interview
stuff got it and all that kind of
started working together so my career
kind of built off of that very cool and
I also must give you such an
appreciation for great interview yes
it's really nice to be talking with
someone that also has that kind of like
experience in that world and also like
host their own things so they know like
it's tough how to keep a cuff it's like
the worst when you walk in and you're
like I'm here to sell your movie for you
yeah and they're like I hate everything
and then you walk in there like yelling
at their assistant and like they're
freaking out you're like great I can't
wait to like show you this gag bit that
I gave that's incredible and now you've
been more focused on music in the last
yeah I mean I think once I got my name
out in Korea outside of I guess that TV
show for like the American Idol stuff
and then it was like okay how can we
start doing more music because that's
what I went to Korea to do yeah I never
wanted to be a TV host sure you know
here's my my theory is everyone that's
TV host I don't think they want to be a
TV host
I'm pretty sure they settled on being a
TV
dreams of grandeur didn't pan out graces
is making a lot of people cry today - TV
host all the time I love it if you need
me you guys in the description it's my
phone number if you know me ask you know
what did you want to do if it wasn't I
wouldn't do comedy okay and so the
comedy and like the hosting stuff was
stuff on the side that I didn't totally
love doing it because I like wanted to
audition in an act and not have to play
myself but then started doing YouTube
where I played myself and I was like I
think I'm actually better at playing
myself than like a character right cuz
all the characters just end up being me
oh it's not acting it's just reading
like it's reality TV yeah exactly that's
what it is so I do have like a super
deep appreciation for hosting cuz it's
so much harder than it looks but I
always feel like people that hosts are
like people that really wanted like some
other avenue right right and then this
worked out better for them would you
oh here's I've been asked to ask you to
explain your appearance on we got
married which is from what I understand
a Korean variety show where two
celebrities act like a married couple
yeah okay yeah that was a very very very
popular show in Korea and I'd say across
all of Asia so the premise is to
celebrities act like a married couple
and then like just go around in public
or so pretty much you are paired up with
another celebrity uh-huh and you don't
know who it is you show up and they're
like a great concept already and they're
like you guys as of today are dating and
are gonna get married and so from that
moment it's you get to know this person
you plan your wedding you find you're
like your newlywed house okay fine your
honeymoon and it's it's like people
vicariously dating through you okay I
guess yeah I mean I watch married at
first sight which is a reality show out
here that people get Pat like paired up
through like experts and they get
married at first sight wait like real
marriage yeah real crazy yeah it's real
good
don't really get me we don't really get
married but we have like a fake fake
real wedding that's been going like a
honeymoon we do all that kind of stuff
okay
and it was on for like probably ten
years Wow
yeah and they had like offshoots in
China uh-huh and it was one of the most
popular shows for a long time oh dang so
I did that for about nine to ten months
nine to ten months wait how many people
do fake wait nine to ten months yeah so
you to do this that you've just string
this out of her nine to ten there who
did you get married to so I was married
to that's like the weirdest thing to say
I was married to this girl group member
her name is solar okay and she's in a
group called mamamoo okay and it's four
very ferocious women okay and it was
cool because like we were like we didn't
really know each other at all and we met
got to become good friends and the rest
is history random and sudden like yeah
like literally these hand you a piece of
paper like as of today you're no longer
married like Oh bye that wasn't yes okay
if you could be a judge on any American
reality show um what would which show
would you be a judge on oh man well to
be fair like I haven't kept up with
American analogy yeah but I think I
think okay can I do too
of course I'm gonna do - I'm gonna cheat
okay I think the voice would be really
cool mm-hmm and shark tank and shark
tank yeah
are you a business-minded I love
startups and I love like new things and
ideas and just like when I see something
like that's really gonna work and I
really want to support an entrepreneur
or whatever and then other people I see
them like that is the worst idea I've
ever heard in my life
I
love the way that there must be a class
on how to present your idea or there
must be just a blank template because
they all come out and they're like hello
sharks
I would like to present you my blah blah
blah I'm asking for it's like so robotic
it gets me every time and the people
that clearly have never taken a public
speaking class in their life uh it hurts
so good
it's god bless have you ever bought any
of the products that you've seen on
check no I haven't oh I have a claim
accidentally scarab no I it was a
backpedal I got a little tipsy one night
and then I was like I need to be healthy
and I went on Amazon and they had this
like weird looking kind of u-shaped it
looked like a melted skateboard and it
was like you stand on it and just wiggle
back and forth and it's supposed to work
your core and I was like that looks easy
and that woman that's in the pictures
having a great time so slam I want that
honestly and then I found out it was a
product from shark tank oh yeah at work
it sits in my Exorcist it's orange it
looks pretty yeah I tried it once but
then I realized that I have terrible
balance and even though this thing's
supposed to stable I do know not for me
I just imagine people tearing ACLs yeah
yeah it seems a little unsafe it seems
it's more for like ants and moms that
want to get into working out oh maybe I
shouldn't rush my aging process it'll be
here we're good we're good okay we're
gonna take a really quick break when we
get back I have more questions for you I
want to talk about music I want to talk
about tour I want to talk about what
you're up to you let's do it we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
to support for today's show comes from
third love with more than 70 sizes
including their signature half cup sizes
third love designs bras with breast size
and shape in mind for a perfect fit and
premium feel you guys have heard me talk
about third love in the past and I still
stay connected with the thought that
they're fantastic they've sent me their
products into some one that wears
basically like ace bandages for bras
these are comfortable fashionable they
make me feel classy and supported all at
the same time they're hands-down the
most comfortable bra that you'll own
they have straps that don't slip they've
tag list labels and not to mention
lightweight super thin memory foam cups
that mold to your shape and are
proprietary to third love best of all
every customer has 60 days to wear it
wash it and put it to the test if you
don't love it you can return it and
third level wash it and donate it to a
woman in need third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you beautiful listeners
15% of your first order go 2/3 love.com
slash grace now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love calm slash grace for
15% off today it's time to turn your
dream into a reality with today's
support from a Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project you want to start a new business
do you want to showcase your work do you
want to publish content do you want to
sell products or more Squarespace is the
tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself they also have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics I
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so there is nothing to
patch or upgrade ever and buying domains
is simple you'll get all the help you
need with their 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people from designers to lawyers
artists gamers even restaurants and gyms
to turn great ideas into something real
so head to squarespace.com slash grace
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain at squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace let's talk about music
you've said on your podcast so you have
too many great songs for your new album
have you narrowed it down at all um okay
so I I've never done like a full-length
album okay I feel like right now with
music everything is single driven every
once in a while you get an EP yes but in
Korea for some reason there's a lot of
weight put on having a full-length LP
really a full album okay which I like
kind of get but then I'm like there's so
many songs that nobody's gonna listen to
you mm-hmm
and it feels like you're just wasting
your songs mm-hmm so it's like a matter
of how do we balance it so I don't feel
like I'm throwing a song this away yeah
I think I have out of like 50 or 60 I've
narrowed it down to like 15 cool that's
him that's a full album right so boy now
you're done I need to like cut it down a
little more okay
and then I want like I I need like one
big single one big thing like I feel
like I have really great songs but I
don't have one that really just punches
somebody in the face and makes them want
to cry and I mean that is like in like
the nicest way possible like the most
non aggressive the visit does the
potential album have a name no no you
want to come up with one for me Shark
Tank baby yeah I mean I mean that's a
little trademark oh really I'm sorry oh
I will sell it to you for a back but so
you basically like that all the things
are there it's just kind of streamlining
and organizing and getting the vibe that
you were because I am I don't know much
about music I'm very I love pop music
that's like the genre that I know the
most about not kpop unfortunately I'm
getting a learning
but the like the ebb and flow of
listening from beginning to end I
imagine this like the emotional journey
you want to take someone on right I
think that's kind of whenever I put
together a package it's like how do we
make it make sense somewhat yeah and
because it's you really do want it to
ebb and flow and have like like a book
has a good climax and like a foreword
and whatever I forgot all those terms
but but it's the hardest part for me is
that I have to put stuff out in Korean
but I write all my stuff in English
really I was gonna ask about that like
what your process is so I usually write
everything in LA people here so they are
essentially just big pop songs yeah and
then we go back and say what would maybe
make sense in Korean and sound okay for
Korean audience that's like the hardest
part yeah that a must stuff must get
lost in translation so what ends up
usually happening happening is the
meaning of the song gets completely
flipped Wow and a perfect like example
of that is last year I put out a song
called in Korean miss you mm-hmm and in
English it was I don't miss you like are
you like what are you crazy like what's
going on like you have too many emotions
no no I'm feeling but that's kind of the
the most difficult part of reverse
engineering things back and also is you
know I want to do music in the States
you know and I want to be able to do
music here I feel like there is no Asian
face doing music mainstream in English
that I can think of right now yeah I
just crazy
I can't are you touring in the States
I'll be oh god I don't know if I want to
say this yes soon cuz this episode won't
come out for a few weeks
yeah it probably won't be released ma'am
but it's cool I mean I we are in the
process of putting together a massive
tour we did a tour last year we did 16
cities and then I just did 12 in Europe
and then I did a some in Australia and
so it's about time to get back in the
States
was there one standout show that you
remember
from tour that was like for better or
worse man I think I guess from the most
recent tour it was so hot we were in
this was in Cologne Germany okay we have
to stop the show like seven times
because people kept feigning and that's
horrifying to see from stage well and
then people are like and the great thing
about kpop fans is they're very like
everybody's so nice yeah and they're
very positive and encouraging and
they're just generally nice and so
people would pass out and that
everybody's whipping out their
flashlights like stop the show so I
remember I restarted a song like two or
three times
Wow because people kept passing out oh
God and that was it was just stressful
because I yeah I don't want people to
die that's a great thing to not want so
that's like always like 'rememorable and
then one of the coolest shows I think is
in Mexico and then one was Minneapolis I
did first Avenue in Minneapolis where
Prince did Purple Rain Wow and I show up
there I don't know anything about
Minneapolis mmm-hmm the venue has like
these stars with everybody who's play
there so like Coldplay and like Nirvana
and chilli peppers whatever prints I was
like it's crazy to me that this asian
kid from Atlanta had to go to Korea to
be back in Minneapolis to sing for a
bunch of people like 1,700 people or
something like that's crazy yeah so I
have I feel like every show that I do is
very memorable and I'm very appreciative
whenever I want stage to be able to do
that that's awesome and how humbling and
weird so many mixed emotions you know
the who cuz so on your podcast you
talked about kpop like community and
like different artists do you have an
artist or a group that you're most
excited about right now I mean I feel
like the entire world is excited about
BTS yeah you know I think that's how did
they how
main question is I feel like and I'm
sure that they've been you know working
forever and then like the you know
flipped script on this is like how did
one direction now and so like what do
you think it was that like made their
crossover like into like mainstream like
music such a yeah I so I have like a few
like theories on this mind you everybody
this is just my personal opinion yes
because they're there it's a very
aggressive fandom its I mean everybody
has like their own opinions on it and so
this is just my personal opinion yes
what you're allowed to have right so my
thing with them is I saw them from when
they debuted they were all my shows I
was interviewing them and from the
beginning in the beginning I've seen
them kind of go through the entire thing
but when they started they were these
underdogs hmm in the industry and that
and I know they were having like a very
difficult time because Korea kpop is so
competitive you have hundreds of group's
debut every year Wow
and it's you know maybe 1% is gonna stay
around for a few years yeah so I
remember that they were they were doing
things non-traditionally in the sense
like they were shooting a show in LA and
they were doing like tiny venues and
they were really just kind of cutting
their teeth I guess just trying to
figure out what their sound and what
their image and their look was gonna be
and I think what really took them there
is their fandom the armies they were
really rooting for that underdog there
were that perfect underdog story mm-hmm
and but it worked because they're
amazing performers they I think the best
way that I've heard it and I think my
brother beside it is like they look like
America's Best Dance Crew but they can
sing and rap at the same time so they're
all triple threats every single one of
you yeah and when you I remember it was
a cake on LA in 20 like 14
okay cons like this big convention for
kpop having like la in New York and they
were like the opening act and it was
like the most stacked lineup that year
yeah it was like the big heavy hitter
from industry they were there and they
were like opening act I was there I was
just like watching them and they stole
the show really because their
choreography and their charisma and the
way they do things people like is that
magic what is going on it and from there
it was like this organic growth of
people like international fans saying
like these kids are so underappreciated
but they're so good yeah they just kept
touring in a way that made sense and
they just sold everything out and now
they're the biggest act in the world
Wow the because at that level you can't
deny talent oh yeah and if they had mean
that's all like Britney Spears kind of
trajectory and like the controversy when
she first came up that was like she
can't like take her auto-tune away like
what's what's going on there but she can
put on a great show and it seems like
with them they if you strip down like
the flashy performance they're still
great singers yeah I mean they they have
the basics there mm-hmm the essentials
is I think that's why it works yeah
that's cool I gotta learn more about it
or I don't I don't know it's such a big
world to get is there's so many things
to do in the world you know what would
you recommend as someone that wants to
start learning more about kpop other
than BTS like who how do I start my
educational journey well I'd say Eric
Nam is a great start okay how do you
spell that he are I see okay okay okay I
think they're a great start
BJ's great start black pink obviously
yeah heard of them they're huge and if
you go on like a YouTube dive we're just
fine the most how many more yeah yeah
just so many I think for people the
sound is now becoming increasingly more
international and pop driven and like my
stuff I've everything that I've been
writing has been in the states with the
best pop writers yeah so what I found is
a lot of people they're like Oh Eric
stuff just sounds like American pop and
some of it's in Korean and so that's
great and then they dive in and they're
like
we ended up with people with purple hair
wear heels but that's cool you know what
it is hey you never know we're gonna
find the Internet has something for
everyone
what's something you always make sure to
keep in your fridge my fridge yeah a lot
of rotting food cool
maybe it's like sriracha sauce I don't
know yeah that's a staple coconut water
there you go there you go you have been
in LA the would you ever be down to be
the next Bachelor oh oh no no no you had
to think about it that would say no
we'll see like I don't get so I walked
into so I'm saying my brothers uh-huh I
walk in yesterday
and they're watching paradise passion
passion paradise
don't give me any spoilers I haven't
watched and they're like so invested
into this yeah like oh my god like blah
blah blah I'm like I don't know what any
of this means but yeah it's from a third
party mm-hmm
it just looks hilarious it is hilarious
it is so ridiculous I don't want to be
on the like but end of a joke like I
don't yeah but no that would be too much
stress man okay okay would you ever be
on it no see I can answer very quickly I
know I would not you still thought about
it
to be fair what's going on here okay
what are you watching on TV right now
Oh what am i watching billions oh I have
not gotten into that dude I mean people
are like yours that such a guy show Mike
what it's a finance show okay but it's I
really I love it my go to these days is
queer i ah yes because I've just been
really stressed and like it makes you
feel so good it makes you feel so good
and if you don't feel good after it
you're looking sociopath okay agree with
that yeah
no it was just like because like the
stories of the people who are getting
helped on there i'm just there's such
heartwarming stories yeah and so
whenever you know after a long day and
i'm just like getting ready for bed i
just leave it on yeah and then I'm just
like okay we're gonna take a quick last
break I'm gonna get back we have a
billion Twitter questions so you know
yeah Twitter's got some stuff that they
need answers to we'll be right back with
more not too deep if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help online counseling can help
they offer licensed professional
counselors who specialize in issues like
depression anxiety relationships trauma
anger family conflicts LGBTQ matters
grief self-esteem
and more connect with your professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment you can get help at your own
time at your own pace
anything you share is confidential and
it's so convenient you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions as well
as chat and text with your therapists
and if for some reason you're not happy
with your counselor they can get you a
new one you can request a new one at any
time for no additional charge and best
of all it's affordable and you beautiful
listeners get 10% off your first month
with the discount code grace so get
started by going to better help calm
slash grace then fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you'll love that's better
help calm slash grace okay we're gonna
get into some Twitter questions but
before we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I asked every single guest
that is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at cold spaghetti
yes oh man I can't see who I want to say
cuz I feel like I'll get in trouble
Oh cold spaghetti yeah I don't know it
doesn't have to be mean it
be like joyous I could who joyously
throws cold spaghetti have you tried it
no but I feel like they would can't say
that conclusion I just imagined my
clammy hands on cold spaghetti and yeah
that's pretty much it yep oh man um oh
my gosh I have no idea you're taking
this very seriously okay syllogism and
these answers can change day to day NRA
oh that's a great answer
I don't think we've had anyone come in
all right yeah I fully support it it's a
it is very very exhausting yeah and
infuriating I would do that and I would
feel good about throwing cold clammy
spaghetti I would applaud yeah okay the
second question is every single guest is
to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call but you can only
tell us in three words or three small
phrases okay so mine for example is
college jogging front lawn that is for
real
Wow yeah sure we have an updated one but
I haven't updated it yet okay yeah all
right here we go
Bolivia okay who is she Bolivia uh-huh
unpaved roads uh-huh
banana trees Oh No completely real Wow
yeah but you guys can imagine it yeah
I'm not gonna ask any follow-up
questions Wow that's dealing gives me
like night shivers thinking about it
yeah that's what's I feel anxious for
you okay let's get into these Twitter
questions the first one is how southern
do you feel Oh like not southern at all
no I mean when I'm in LA I was in
Atlanta what like a month ago
my brother's engagement party and that I
felt really southern then yeah when I'm
there I
because what I realized is when I speak
to people and if they have an accent
just I have it you mirror yeah yeah if
I'm in London all of a sudden I'm doing
some crazy I don't even like it's weird
yeah I do the same thing so all of a
sudden I was and I was in Nashville for
songwriting sessions and Atlanta so for
like a week I was talking like this it's
like hey y'all so I really want to write
a song it's about like whatever and I'm
just like I'm you know I'm gonna die
yeah it was weird
that's when I feel most southern and I
also feel like a fraud but that's about
it yeah someone snow what is your
favorite hobby my favorite hobby
Oh what are you doing your downtime your
free time if you have any Emily I really
don't have any you you go to Vegas for
bachelor parties like it's like
stressing me out I think it's just
grabbing a drink with friends that's
about it yeah that's like the the
coolest thing for me to do just grab a
glass of whiskey that's very cool that
sounds very cool very boring so I wants
to know what's the most difficult part
of starting your podcast everything okay
okay so I don't know so Brian my brother
was like like you need to do podcast I
was like why and to be fair it's like in
Korean nobody's really doing podcast
really okay it's now just starting to be
on people's radar because I started one
and then my friend had will just started
his so Brian's like we need to do this
as like I really don't want to but if
you really think I should we'll try it
so it's on my kitchen table okay this
one condenser mic from 10 years ago
uh-huh
and it was horrible like it was a really
good advertisement people haven't heard
of your podcast
I hate doing it it's terrible please
listen to me you liked hearing people
just talk crap like
it's gonna be great for you but I mean I
say that because we I mean we've got
into a really good place now we we
figured out the formula we figured out
how to do it our good friend Katrina
here is editing this stuff we found out
right before that Katrina that shoots
and edits these episodes it also works
with you yes nice to meet you Katrina
you at 3:00 a.m. on slack Katrina it's
like I can answer this question about
the hard Treena wasn't even there for
like the first what few episodes but she
definitely brought her came up a lot
yeah cuz it was just like us dropping
[ __ ] and like crinkling everything and
he would be like typing at his computer
was just bad yeah but if you listen from
the beginning which I do not recommend
there is a general up uptick in the
quality okay and the content that's good
so it gives things to look forward to
like will the audio be okay right later
than people like you sound like you're
an echo chamber what's going on we are
in a hallway yeah just trying to get
this done and so for people that don't
know that should go check out the
podcast what is the general premise of
it so if I haven't already given you a
thousand reasons to love this it's
pretty much you know there's a lot of
kpop and I think we just try to dive
into like our top three picks for the
week mm-hmm we kind of explain the song
what it's about the music video
and then we ramble about if I have met
that person or that team like what
they're like and then I just talked
talked [ __ ] with my brothers that sounds
great it's yeah it's it's a solid medium
it's a solid medium and any I think what
it is is I I feel like cringy talking
about it sometime sure because I it's
weird to me that people would listen to
me like do you ever have that Oh 100%
yeah I don't know how it's still
happening I think they're all kind of
placating me in this building and like
none of these are actually on is keep
coming in my grace pretender
I'd like and I think that's it's a very
humbling experience to do it and so like
I I appreciate people who do listen to
it but I think what I have realized is
like there is definitely an audience
that appreciates like the insight into
kpop in like my life but it's given me
it's made me think that I wanted to do
another podcast that's completely
different
cool that's just kind of like what
you're doing yeah just meeting
interesting people and not have it be
around one certain topic that's I think
that works in your skill set too because
you have so much experience interviewing
people that if you get to do it on your
own terms and not in a four minute like
hyper-aggressive window okay someone to
know what is the sweetest thing a girl
did for you um oh man it's just I can't
talk about it nice surprises here and
there that just completely unexpected
that's sweet yeah okay who do you think
has the hardest job in the music / k-pop
industry oh man as a tough question I'd
say in Korea it's like managers yeah and
I'd say that because in the state in the
sense of like in the States a manager is
supposed to be like your biz dev and
like mm-hmm a guy in Korea like a
manager a lot of them are just Road
manage they just drive you around oh
they're like your personal assistant
okay but they're up before you they go
to sleep after you they're driving you
everywhere they take care of everything
mm-hmm and as hard as our jobs are as
celebrities or as singers or performers
like my heart always goes out to the
person like behind the scenes thing yeah
and care of that person yeah basically
like a parent yeah they get like there
and they're the first ones to get in
trouble for everything too sure and
that's why I'm just like you guys there
they have the hardest job
that's not fair but also how great to be
able to acknowledge respect for that
yeah I have to yeah yeah I have to um
someone wants to know and you could ever
if you ever could go back in time and
fix
something you regret or didn't like what
would it be
it's happening take a sip of coffee and
then an ice cube went into my mouth and
I realized I couldn't answer it's nice
but Becky can you reach that question
God if you ever could go back in time
and fix something you regret or didn't
like what would it be
Oh fix something I didn't like or regret
mmm
I mean I feel like Bolivia might be on
the list you know what I don't I really
first of all I have a horrible memory
I've like the worst memories name it's
awful and I worry that people think it's
me being a [ __ ] but it's really I can't
ever remember names things that happened
yeah if I if we run into each other and
I don't say hi or ever I don't please
don't take it personally I'll be like
you were on my podcast so like yeah it's
whatever people ask me this question I'm
like I don't remember anything about my
life that means that you don't have any
regrets
you carefree I'm very carefree and
stressed all the time but I think I
think if anything I would I just partied
when I was okay yeah I think I was very
like very responsible like get your [ __ ]
done constantly like yeah it is great
but when you live and you look back you
like it wasn't a big deal
yeah that's true also you have like the
young person stamina to party more right
if you try to make up for lost time as
an adult
yeah things hurt more yeah it's just
Trust trust me on this please like when
I tell you to party now just party now
yeah I mean within reason yeah yeah be
said someone's asking favorite American
artist Oh that tough that's hard that's
like asking to pick your favorite parent
oh wow okay um how about for right now
sure fluctuates all the time oh man I've
been listening to a lot of Lainey I
don't really know much about them but I
really like their music degree and why
yeah cool that and then Bruno Mars is
always just like a role model yeah in
terms of Howie I don't think there's a
solo male artist right now that can sing
and dance and perform at his caliber
yeah he's like the pretty incredible
yeah
what emoji do you use the most this one
the wink with the tongue yeah and you're
kind of smiling but you look like you're
having a seizure yeah what does that one
mean like what are you using it for it
to like what a motion to denote my
complicated internalized but still
trying to have a good time exactly when
did you realize you could sing um I
thought I could sing at a very young age
uh-huh my parents told me otherwise
until I was like 22 Wow it was my
parents just did not like the idea that
I would even want to be a singer but
what a clever way for parents to keep
their kids from entering a career path
that they didn't approve of you just
tell them that they're bad at it yeah
there was no shortage of that right my
parents like I think back on it and like
my both my brothers they played d1
college soccer okay and so they're like
I love soccer - growing up I was on
varsity from freshman year and but
they're like you need to stop like why
is it you're horrible it's like I'm the
only freshman on the teams like you
always encourage they're like your
brothers they're good you are subpar you
should just study and play like an
instrument that should hate playing and
so they kept me playing like the cello
and I never really liked it but they're
like that's what you should do yeah but
it's like but I want to sing they like
well then you should take Opera lessons
I was like I tried it for one and I'm
like this is horrendous
I said I'm like a dying cat yeah
so I always like just saying for fun and
like YouTube was kind of like that
outlet mm-hmm and when I got onto like
the American Idol show it was funny cuz
I call my parents and I was like hey so
I think I would good shot like the
producers really liked me the writers
like me like I don't know I feel like it
might work out my mom goes Erik just get
it out of your system I'm glad you're in
Korea so you finally know and you'll
finally understand how not great you are
you will finally realize that there are
so many talented people people who are
more talented than you are in music and
singing and you will finally just go
work at a job it's like thanks mom I
love you too bye what do they think now
um they love it now okay everyone so mom
stills like someone you're gonna get a
real job um but my dad is all about it I
think if he could he would be a
celebrity himself we did a TV show
together where we traveled to Prague oh
wow and he became like a semi celebrity
for a few years and he was like loving
it when is my endorsement deal for the
ramen coming in I was like okay dad my
mom was like even till like 2 or 3 years
ago she came to visit me in Korea and
she's like so people like know you I was
like yeah so people like recognized she
is like yes so like they like you though
yes like mom my face I'm like literally
as you saying this there's a bus with my
face on it shouting I don't remember
what it was I was like holding something
like cosmetic product I was like mom
that's my face on a bus and she's like
why I was like I'm sorry I'm such a
disappointment I love you things he
wants to accomplish in the next 10 years
oh wow
I think my biggest goal is to really try
to do stuff here in the States
yeah and I think you know Asians Asian
Americans were having
kind of a moment especially with you
know BTS kpop doing the music and then
with like crazy rich Asians and like the
shang-chi movie and all these people in
film and TV having said that I still
don't see a single solo artist or Asian
American doing things in English yeah
you know and it needs to happen and I
think people we've like set it up so
that somebody can do it mm-hmm I don't
know if it'll be me but I'd like to be
part of that process to make it possible
for some kid in the future that's cool
and that's probably like my biggest goal
very cool so that's what I'm working
towards very admirable well thank you
I'm also like very specific I've thought
about a lot yeah that's awesome
how did you get the courage to just Oh
to just leave the US and move to Korea
which obviously it happened in phases
Wow
how did you get the courage to move out
of the u.s. it was so a lot of people
asked me like I guess as a counterpoint
to that not count like whatever is why
did you choose to go to Korea and start
music there and I was like I didn't have
a choice you know yeah we didn't have a
choice like you think you walk any Asian
girl or guy into a major label you think
they're gonna sign them hell no even
right now they're it's all about right
now I feel like it's about numbers yeah
who has the biggest social following
yeah whatever
so for me my answer is always like if I
wanted to seriously pursue music it was
to go where I was accepted and that for
me was Korea so it was terrifying it was
daunting I don't have friends out there
I couldn't speak the language really and
I felt uncomfortable forever but I felt
like I needed to be done and that was
you know everything's for a dream and
like a purpose and a goal and for me
like I felt like that was part of that
journey also just throwing it out there
uncomfortable forever is a great name
for an album okay you don't get producer
credit trademark that so we use
right by the website now
okay we're wrapping up let me see if I
have one more a really good question
let's see okay what's your favorite
thing to do these days my favorite thing
to do these days sleep okay when I can
actually no I don't like sleeping do you
like sleeping I love sleeping when I can
do it right it's it's not my strongest
skill set I'm really bad at it
me too and I and that stresses me out
which leads me to not sleep nearly there
and you're like why am I not sleeping
yeah I mean that you get yeah it's an
endless cycle right it's horrible
favorite thing to do is do my podcast
sweetie the one that you hate so much a
really good final question what's his
favorite thing to do with a hot dog what
I think that came from Twitter I came
from they named themselves the gay that
texts you at weird times these are your
fans whoa and he wants baby want to know
what's the favorite thing to do with the
hot dog who eat it what like what do you
do with the hot dog man your brain
imagine what you not gonna go there
there's a bumble baby here like yeah
that's you my best friend just painted
with a hot dog on a YouTube video so
that's what we're at 2018 Eric thank you
so much for being here thank you for
having me of course but before you go
every single guest that then the podcast
gets a parting gift and that's a fortune
cookie from us to you oh gosh
it's got a personalized fortune inside
wait did you personalize who
personalized our team I want to know is
this like a panda express
personalization it's like a real place
just like we actually personally oh wow
that's cool that's a lot of effort wait
do we try on the podcast okay wait I'm
gonna open it up go ahead
I like when you're announcing all right
whoa all right here we go
there's no such thing as too many
fingers for a new album let's go 56 new
songs for the new album this is a
promise to your fans listening just
because I read it does not mean it is a
promise statement that I read for a
piece of paper
yeah just saying it's a possibility that
is possibility that would probably not
happen okay but is you know I think
it'll be out in November and it's gonna
be a lot of really great songs
someday it'll be followed by tours so
hopefully I'll see you guys yeah I am
where can people find you and everything
you're up to if they don't know on my
Instagram it's real Eric Nam okay let me
spell that out for you re al real uh-huh
Eric er IC with a C uh-huh hey that was
your Eric with the C nah man a.m. and
Eric Nam Kham everything's there
Eric Nam Kham yeah thank you so much
thank you this was so fun last I will
thank God whew
thanks for listening guys I will see you
next time on another episode of not too
deep Gabon good well he can sing good
boy 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]